hey guys pete here today i'm gonna take
a look at raised by wolves
season one episodes eight and nine they
just dropped together
and while a lot happened in these two
episodes mass
and umbilical they were kind of short on
answers which means there's a lot riding
on the finale next week
but before we get ahead of ourselves
let's talk about what happened and what
mother's big twist
might mean for the story going forward
as a warning
if you haven't watched episodes 8 and 9
of raised by wolves
then this video will definitely contain
spoilers hit the subscribe button
go watch them and then come back here
after you've finished
episode 8 starts off with marcus cutting
his new face away in a dream he spends
most of this episode
having a hard time trying to figure out
what to do next
now that the voice has stopped talking
to him he's starting to get paranoid too
and it turns out he has a reason to be
as sue and paul
are planning on going on an adventure
without him she's going back and forth
between the feelings she has for marcus
and wanting to protect paul and get away
from the mithraics
paul is concerned about his friend
campion and visits him to give him
food we see that he's in there trying to
ignore ghost
tally by reciting the jokes that father
used to tell him
and he's trying to dig his way out of
his prison things come to a head when
marcus flips out on paul
and sue intervenes trying to take him
away
she ends up locked up and marcus has
everyone pray for her
because at that point he doesn't know
what else to do he's pretty much at his
wit's end
concerned that he might be crazy but at
the same time this former atheist
seems to believe that saul's voice might
provide him a way out
with the help of the claws of the dead
creature
campion is able to dig his way out of
his cell
he sets fire to the church which marcus
interprets as the sign he was asking for
this causes chaos in the camp so that
campion can flee
although father sees him and gives chase
paul is able to free his mother
so that they can put their plan into
action and holly and vida decide that
they want to leave with them they break
for the lander only to find out they
can't use it
and then take off into the woods where
they later reunite with campion who was
able to get away from
father mother spends the episode at the
crashed ark
she finds a working medical android
inside who helps her figure out what's
going on with her body
and gives us more insight into what
makes the necromancer
androids possible the fifth force of
nature was mentioned in the companion
comic book they released this week
and carl fills in the rest of the
details they refer to this as dark
photon
and it's something that isn't actually
understood by the mithraics
they were just interpreting instructions
that were encrypted in their holy
scriptures
this is an interesting development but
not the most
interesting development because we also
find out that mother is carrying a child
which should obviously not be possible
after draining all the fuel blood from
the androids she can find
in an effort to try to feed her baby
mother realizes that it isn't working
and moves on to plasma
after killing a creature when she
finishes draining that she runs into
tempest
she has to send her away briefly because
she finds herself torn between the urge
to protect her
and to take her blood to feed her fetus
after they split
mother finds a sim pod where she talks
to the voice of champion sturgis
who confirms her pregnancy telling her
that it is the real mission
he says the other children were
basically a test and now the real future
of humanity is inside of her
in the beginning of episode 9 tempest
comes face to face with a rapist otho
before she can have her revenge though
mother swoops in
realizing that he could be her fetuses
new source of plasma
she starts to drain him by hooking up
what looks like an
umbilical cord and the trio take off
heading towards where mother says
her delivery will have the best chance
of being successful
they're lured into a canyon by the
reflection from metal tarot
cards we saw the host character inside
the serpent skeleton hideaway take these
from marcus before he fled
it's implied that he's the one that set
these up and is watching them from a
distance
we don't get a look at him but we can
hear breathing
as he looks on which might confirm that
he's not an android
sue and the others arrive initially she
wants to kill mother but the children
won't let her
after she reveals she's pregnant things
calm down
and everyone decides to work together
more or less there's a strange moment
where campion says hello to the fetus
and it seems to have an
adverse reaction to his presence from
there they move mother into a cave where
they can better take care of her
this gives the two women a chance to
talk mother reveals she knows who
is an atheist imposter and they form an
uneasy alliance
on the other side of things marcus is
still at a loss for what soul wants him
to do
he cuts off father's tapping finger
which sets things in motion for hunter
to revert him to his old self
earlier he had noticed that the finger
was tapping out morse code and was
surprised to learn that it translated to
saul as the light
this turned out to be the password which
he used to bring the old father back
for once doing something other than
being a little prick
and i have to say it was fantastic to
get father back
watching his facial expression shift
ever so
slightly was a great payoff marcus
decides to take the lander to the temple
in a last-ditch effort to force saul's
hand
when that doesn't work he tries to get
answers from hunter who was out of the
loop and really doesn't know where su
and the other kids went when marcus
forces his arm into this
hole on the temple's wall the one that
he just used to light a torch
somehow hunter isn't harmed it's an
interesting development but they don't
linger on it long because at the first
chance father and hunter steal the
lander and take off
back at the cave mother goes off alone
and experiences what i guess you could
call a vision when she scans one of the
tarot cards
she sees a bunch of cloaked figures in
black standing around one of the holes
in the ground on kepler-22b
there's what looks like an alien inside
a
cage a dodecahedron cage maybe
it's not really clear what it is or
what's going on there's fluid coming out
of the being's mouth and that looks
similar to
the fuel blood but before she can figure
out what's going on
mother is snapped out of it this is
because the flow of blood coming from
otho has reversed so that a mix of hers
or possibly her fetuses is now flowing
into him
this turns him into super oh though who
runs a muck
until the girls are able to kill him
holly distracts him long enough for
tempest
to grab the prison droid's head and she
throws it far enough away that the
helmet finally flattens his skull
after that hunter and father arrive
mother is drained
from the otho reversal situation but sue
gives her a pint of blood and the baby
seems to be all right
and as everyone's settling in paul
starts to hear the voice
that draws him away from the others he's
led outside to the tarot cards and he
throws them on the fire
then he goes back inside and tells
campion that soul put the baby into
mother
and when asked how he knows he just says
he can feel it and that saul
isn't evil after hunter and father left
with the lander things started to fall
apart
for marcus eventually he's exposed as an
imposter
and lucius decides to make a move on him
he beats him down
and then shoves one or maybe both of
mothers necromancer eyes in his mouth
it's hard to tell for sure
even when you look at it frame by frame
but he forces at least one of her eyes
in his mouth
walking away leaving him for dead or
letting
saul's will be done because the episode
ends there
so yeah a lot of stuff happened but not
a lot of clear answers
i suspect that marcus isn't dead like
dead dead
as in that's the last we'll see of the
character the whole
super oatho thing seems kinda
unnecessary if it wasn't there to show
us
that the dark photons or necromancer
blood produce
interesting side effects when they get
inside humans
i expect that using the eyes will have
some kind of effect on marcus
and since the other soldiers left him
there i'm guessing the host character
will probably rescue him
and then maybe finally that will lead to
some answers about his identity
i mean there are strong clues that he
may be related to the devil cults that
tempest mentioned
and otho chimed in on the tarot cards at
least are connected to them
and they mentioned that these cults were
purged more than once now
when mother scanned the card she saw
what looked like cult members
so perhaps they were purged by being
sent to kepler-22b
another clue for that is this new
website they made for the show that
popped up over the last couple of days
once you uncover all the sights the
easter egg that appears is this image of
a ship
it says it's a tarantula large ship
capable of transporting
redacted approach with caution energy
signature unknown
inhabitants currently unidentified
what's the redacted word
prisoners i'm not sure but it could be
connected
the being in the dodecahedron cage thing
looks alien to me
but the beings surrounding it look
humanoid so
there were either human-like creatures
or humans that evolved on kepler
or some were sent from earth prior to
mother and father
arriving on the planet there was a lot
to like about these two episodes
the reunions were all good and overall
it seems like a good thing that all
these characters are together and more
or less on the same side father's coming
back his personality coming back was
definitely a highlight
and one of my favorite parts carl the
medical droid was also pretty cool and
i enjoyed all of his interactions with
mother
there are parallels in tempest and
mother situations
they're both pregnant now neither was a
willing participant
and neither is very happy about it so
you can see how they might
form a friendship or a different kind of
relationship
in the circumstance also you can imagine
sue and mother becoming close
we saw them bond a little whenever sue
gave her the blood
and you can see things moving forward
there paul and campion seem to be drawn
together again
and the voice seems to have moved on to
talking to paul
i made a theory video the other day
about the voices
and i still think it's connected to what
mother
called the virus and the sim who
appeared to her as her creator
but i think this episode showed that the
host isn't on the same
side i mean check out that video if you
haven't seen it
and then think about the voice leading
paul to destroy the cards
those seemed important to the hosts so
there could be
two different factions operating on
kepler beyond the
androids and the methraics holly finding
the tooth of romulus was an interesting
nod to that story
a lot of people have been mentioning the
parallels there
with romulus and remus being raised by
wolves and
founding rome and now they've introduced
this holy relic that is literally
connected to that
as part of their faith the dark photon
stuff is also interesting
the showrunner creator aaron guzikowski
has talked about choosing mithraism
because it was a real religion that was
very secretive and therefore there
wasn't a lot that was known about it
he's basically confirmed that this isn't
an alternate reality situation where
christianity didn't exist
but instead that mithraism reemerged and
took over
in the 22nd century there are no written
texts that have been discovered
so it's interesting that he used the
idea
of them discovering how to use dark
photon energy
through encrypted instructions in their
scriptures
makes you wonder when those scriptures
were discovered and
if they might have been sent to earth
for nefarious purposes
it also makes you wonder if her saving
or reviving the stillborn campion if
that's related to dark photon energy as
well
he seems to be different than the other
children he survived the radiation of
the carbos
and now that we know that she's powered
by this mysterious
fifth force of nature he might have some
of that running through his veins as
well
there are still so many unanswered
questions and it's kind of crazy
in kind of worrying me a bit about this
season finale
i hope they can pull it all together the
shirt owner did say that we are going to
learn
what's going on inside the holes and he
also said in an
interview that the creatures are coming
back as they were trapped underground
when the ark crashed that's when they
started to show up
as in they were released from the
underground in one way or the other
so we should get some answers there like
i said my
personal theory is that the host
character will come in contact with
marcus and that will hopefully lead to
us finding out who he is and hopefully
we'll learn more about
whoever was on kepler-22 prior to this
current
wave of colonists and how that all
led to this situation where people are
hearing voices and seeing dead kids
and everything else that's going on in
the planet so i think
i will leave it there i'm excited to see
where it goes
i'm excited to see what you guys think
so let me know in the comments
what you're hoping to get answers for
what you're hoping will happen
what are your favorite theories i may do
another theory video this week
once i think about this a little bit
more i wanted to get this video out
first and then i'll think about that
later on
let me know if there's something you
want to see please like the video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon